in case you forgot just how great
LaDainian Tomlinson was here's one stat
to remind you let's go back to 2006
because this is the year that people
said LT had the best fantasy season of
all time he scored 31 total touchdowns
which is an all-time NFL record but
here's where your mind is going to
explode the 186 points that he scored
for the Chargers by himself that was
more points than the Raiders score that
entire year how is that even possible
the Raiders were awful that year and
finished the season 2 and 14. they
scored just 168 points compared to lt's
186. here's where it gets even crazier
the Raiders kicker Sebastian Janikowski
scored 70 of their points and their
defense scored 26 points which means
their offense only scored 12 touchdowns
which is almost 20 less touchdowns that
LT scored by himself so the next time
you hear someone disrespecting LaDainian
Tomlinson remind them that